yeah that agent um I contacted on March
10 to be able to communicate
okay 498
David Norwich actually Florida
[Music]
not behind us
[Music]
back in here
[Music]
[Music]
important
okay
[Music]
okay
anyone
[Music]
I think that 29 miles
[Music]
put me up here
okay
[Music]
clarification try to find out where he
actually did at the FBI office
[Music]
internally
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
thank you
the right thing with White Lane and uh
heavy miles per hour
he has not made any uh
any Improvement out of this way
[Music]
things
[Music]
get over
here
[Music]
[Music]
finder
or northbound 29.
okay
[Music]
three guys
who advised if you want me to pass the
park in sir 547's requests
[Music]
[Music]
thank you 96 we are passing away today
[Music]
okay or now Northbound 31 coming out
behind the 1895
okay I'm back in traffic off just in
case
[Music]
okay
Columbus learning units
[Music]
okay
[Music]
everybody
[Music]
welcome
[Music]
before we get to you
hello
bye
okay
1991 do you have your mom been out
[Music]
here
don't worry about that
[Music]
right lane now you have anyone else
[Music]
[Music]
okay we just came over tomorrow
[Music]
head over
get over
from now
[Music]
1896 you're gonna take the uh
better than alcohol
[Music]
burn but I think put your front take
down girl
I feel pretty good distance
between Katrina
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
right
okay
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm taking off
it okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I don't think he did any but picking on
the cell phones
guys back on me
don't get shot
[Music]
okay
haven't heard any more trucks yet
[Music]
it sounded like a shotgun
well
packing off UK for a little bit more
distance
[Music]
22 an hour 73 71 would stop six
okay be advised if you didn't hear he
did fire already
[Music]
behind cover
for 73 and then they didn't get to pick
out Friday we parked in there
if I get off a little bit
73 now 73 exit we're a mile away 44.
walkway walkway now
I have to cross over left leg
go up way approaching the overpower
we're playing it hurts me over back
[Music]
after the imagining
[Music]
I'm on the way up and we are entering a
family reacting at 73.
[Music]
still on the ramp
uh Louisiana
[Music]
[Music]
73 passing 380 in traffic about 40 miles
from
foreign
[Music]
Aviation is about 30 minutes out and
helicopter is about 30 minutes out
and they will be on this frequency
okay what kind of vehicle 79's got stop
six dead out 473
about a mile
for appointments on 71.
if your glasses three
[Music]
on the left side
don't watch the
professional Ron Smith Ron Smith now
north of is this the dead end
[Music]
uh
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
show me your hands show me your hands
get on the ground get on the ground
let me see your hands